على كلا ينضم الينا من رياض الناقد
سينمائي طارق الخواجي سيد طارق اهلا بك
يسعد صباحك منورنا في صباح العربيه
السينما السعوديه تتجه لانتاج 100 فيلم
بحلول 20 30 اهميه تصاعد الحركه الانتاجيه
والنوعيه في المملكه سينمائيه
همم صباح الخير جميعا تحيه لك وساده
المشاهدين همم اعتقد انه هذا الاتجاه همم
يعبر عن رغبه كبيره جدا في التعبير هناك
الكثير من القصص والمواضيع والهواجس
والافكار التي تحيط بكل لسان في العالم
همم اعتقد ان هذه الفكره مهمه جدا للتعبير
عن المجتمع السعودي وعن همم
المستقبل واعتقد ان السينما واحده من
ادوات المهمه جدا للتعبير في العصر الحديث
هي همم قد تكون عمره 100 عام لكن ما زالت
حاضره ومهمه جدا ولها كثير من المتابعين
حول العالم
اه طيب همم طارق اليوم لفتره طويله يعني
كان العرب يصورون في الافلام الغربيه
بطريقه سلبيه ودائما البطل هو الغربي
طالما نحن لدينا الامكانيات ولدينا
الموارد هل نحن نفتقر ربما للقدره
والامكانيه على تصوير انفسنا بالشكل
اللازم والشكل الكافي للعالم
همم اعتقد انه يعني هو سؤال دائما عن من
يعبر عن الاخر بطريقه افضل ودائما هو كما
يقول افلاطون يعني كان يقول تحدث حتى اعرف
يعني فاذا همم قدمنا افلام غالب سوف يصنع
العالم عندك تصورات معينه الفكره التصور
عن نفسك هي لا تاتي من فيلمين ولكن من
تراكم معين الاعلام اللي هناك ما يعرف
بالسلام الكوريه سينما الايرانيه وهي ليست
من خلال كلمه من خلال تراكم معين صار على
هذه السينما سمعتها واصبحت بشكل تعبر عن
هذه القوميات فانا اعتقد انه العالم
العربي بسواء يعني من الانتاجات المصريه
المبكره وكذلك كثير من اعمال السينمائيه
المميزه التي خرجت مثلا من المغرب العربي
ولا من لبنان ولا من همم يعني همم
يعني مختلفه بالعالم العربي عبر بشكل
مختلف عن هويات متعدده واعتقد انه كان
ايضا السعوديه
همم واعتقد انه همم هذه تضم ضمن اشيائه
اخرى بدات تشير ببناء العالم العربي يعني
بالامس اكثرنا ملف كاس العالم في قطر
واعتقد انه هذا قدم صوره مختلفه وايجابي
عن العرب اليوم البشت اصبح يعني له حضور
كبير جدا بسبب يعني اخذ فكره معينه فاعتقد
انه مثل هذا النوع من ال ال ال التوجه الى
العالم من خلال الصوره سيكون له فائده
كبيره جدا في تصوير العرب طيب سي طارق
شاهدنا في السعوديه زياده كبيره في
ميزانيه الممدوده بانتاج السينمائي وزياده
الانتاج السينمائي السعودي للافلام
السعوديه تحديدا لكن السؤال ما هي ابرز
التحديات التي قد تواجه العمل سينمائي في
السعوديه خصوصا مع الطموح لان تتصدر
السينما العربيه
يعني انا اعتقد انه في هذا المرحله مهم
جدا ان نستوعب ان نحن في مرحله متقدمه جدا
من السينما وليس هناك مجال ولا مساحه ان
ينتظر الاخر تطور هذه الصناعه سينمائيه في
السعوديه حتى تصبح موازيه يجب ان نفذ
قفزات كبيره جدا حتى نصل لجذب الانتباه
بمعنى انه لن يلتفت الناس الى افلام التي
ستنتجها المملكه ما لم تكون افلام جيده
مكتوبه بعنايه منفذه باحترافيه انتاج جيد
وتمثيل واداء يعني يكون على قدر المستوى
الذي يجذب الاخرين ولذلك انا اعتقد ان نحن
لسنا في مرحله فيلم سعودي جيد وانما يجب
علينا ان نذهب الى مرحله فيلم جيد طيب
فيلم جيد طارق هل ستتحقق الرؤيا السعوديه
المطلوبه بانتاج فعلا 100 فيلم بحلول عام
20 30 هل كل الامكانيات موجوده هل المواهب
الكوادر والموارد متوفره بالشكل الكافي
والكامل
يعني على الدعم مثلا هناك عده مؤسسات في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه تدعم بشكل كبير
جدا انتاج الافلام هناك كوادر سواء وطنيه
او عربيه قادره على انها يعني تعمل مع بعض
لتحقيق هذا الانجاح يعني هذا الرقم اللي
يبدو الى الان يعني انه رقم كبير جدا
وكذلك اعتقد انه في استديوهات وفي عرض وفي
جمهور يشاهد في مهرجانات سينما في
السعوديه في مهرجان السعوديه
بعد الانتاج فانا اعتقد انه هذه كلها
ستعمل بشكل كبير جدا في انها تساعد هناك
اقسام الدراسيه الان اصبح مخصصه للسينما
وهناك ايضا بني تحتيه يعني
تطور بشكل كبير جدا همم
اماكن للتصوير يعني تسهيلات كبيره جدا
للانتاج سنه معي فاعتقد ان هذه مع مع جمله
الانتاجات وجمله عفوا المبادرات التي تخرج
من هنا وهناك ستساعد بشكل كبير جدا في
الوصول الى
هذا واحنا بنشكرك جزيه للشكر يا طارق من
الرياض ناقد سينمائي طارق خواجه شكرا لك